Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Super Mario Maker
now we're halfway through the challenge
with more than half our lives left
which typically means that we're gonna be ok
and I even got a normal controller instead of the game pad
which might make it just a little bit easier to get through this challenge
or it's gonna cripple me, hinder me, I'm gonna cry
into my body pillow tonight just sobbing helplessly
anyway, so, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, oohh, no, no, ok
alright. I already don't like this. Oh nooo
aahhh! ok
haaa that was unnecessary but I did it anyway
cause I like to l-aaahh
I like to live
*laughing* I like to live in life
ok, so this, at least this one's not as bad as the spiky one that we've seen in prior levels
because that one was just a load of dicketry
so if I can just get through this with minimal loss of shroomage
oh shit, did it anyway
aah! ooohhhhhh
so I don't even know if what I did was very skillful but I'm gonna assume that I'm doin ok
oop oh oh I might be able to get one of those guys
hup shit
shh fuck na god, did it wrong
wooh ah where am I goin, where am I goin, what am I ah
I jumped right into that
there was no point to anything that I was doing besides doing that
ok, but I saw another way down that was like a fireflower over on the leftern side so
if I can just do that
boink
ok there's no way to avoid that there
but there is, ah shit
just a little too much
a little too much
hup, ok
so there is a way down on the right path over here that I can see
oh stop throwing things. Right down there
so if I'm, oh shit
damnit boost oh what the hell? How did I fall through?
I don't even know what just happened
ok so if I damage boost through there
then I should be able to make it all the way to the end
and I'm hopin that I'm gonna do this in a timely manner
because I've already lost quite a few lives
oh yes
ah shit, ok
just speed, speed, speed, done
alright, so get that
ok so I just gotta get through here without losing
ok, here we go
I don't, I don't know how that worked bef-ok
there we go, got it, and then there's the, oh shit
well I guess I gotta lose one more but that's ok
yes, ok, I've got this, does this help me?
oh shit, I'm wasting it, I'm wasting it
I'm wasting all of my potential
oh shit, oh no, I'm wasting it
ah god I wasted it
I wasted it all, I wasted it so much
oh why did I, no, oh, oh, what do you, ahh
fuuuuuuuuuucccccckkkk
so I've only lost four lives on this one level
which means that I've got a lot more
I was not even frickin' paying attention there
I was looking at another screen
ok, fuck
ah da da, ok, it doesn't matter there
I'm just doing what I can to get by here
so long as I'm going quick enough
shouldn't be, oh frick
nooooo fuck goddamn it
oh man I don't even know where the other way to go was, it was like down the right crack of that
I think I can fall down
I-I didn't try there because I'm stupid
ok, off we go
shit
oh god, ok
huuuu fuck goddamn it, it's too close
oh it's so scary
oh hello, god just the situation of them throwing it blindly from abo-ffffuck
now I gotta go th- ah
ffffudge, man this one is hard
I thought for in the beginning that it was gonna be manageable and ok, but this one is
actually, urrggghh
it's ok, it's ok, it's ok
it's ok, it's ok
and it's actually not that difficult, the only problem area is just the unpredictability
see like that? ok
so that is apparently a solution
I can't get, ah, sh, I just can't get through there
ok it doesn't matter cause so long as I grab this star
and go, ah fuck, come on
there, go, aaahhh aahhh ahhh
come get ahhh
gaaaaa
I wasted it again
aaahhh fuck
ahh I had that goddamn it
just a spike me up the grundle
but I can get through this it's not a big deal, oh f-waaa
does that fuck you
uhhhhhhhh
don't waste it, oh this is exactly the definition of wasting it
this, this, this is completely wasting it
ahh fuck it's wasting it
it's wasting it
ahhh fuck, ahhhhhhh
what the hell happened here
wooo k I oooh
this level is...odd
it's oddly made
it's, the rules are a little bizzare
ah fucking crimety chris oh really
really?
I'm gonna go get that because
there was no point otherwise
ok, hup, get up, oooh
really? oh really?
oh really?
f fuck you get out of my way
no, oh, fuck off
urgh
I shouldda twirl jumped, god I shouldda twirl jumped
I shouldda twirl jumped
ooohhhhh it's ok
I think I got it this time
because at least I'm gonna be more coordinated
in the problem areas
see just like that and then just like that, I already know what I'm doing
it's just that I haven't been doing it properly
I know, I know
I, I don't even know why I would go for that
ok get that, get that
*exhale* see just with the that
and the that, ok
oh fuck, ah fuck, oh what I didn't know that I was gonna go
it's probably like right there, the end is probably right there
it's right there, isn't it?
I'm not gonna lose it all here
nooooo noooooo
nooo noooo
noooo noooo
they're all gonna laugh at you
ahhh ok, it's fine
it's fine, it's fff oh would you fucking asshole
you asshole, why would you do that?
why would you oh fuck
goddamn it why would you do that
ugghhhgbbbbblllhhh
fuck fifty, goddamn it fifty
I've lost sixteen
on this level alone
I just want to get through the expert challenge, I don't want to start over again
god how hard is that to understand?
eh, eeehhh
just get it, god, just get it
just get it, oh sassifrass
oh fuck, oh fuck, god
ffff aaaaaahhhhhhh
this is unreal, why is this so hard for me? it's not that hard
this li- this really, really this one's not that hard
but for some reason it's givin me conniptions
conniptions
fwah fuck you man, fuck you, fuck
right ooofffff with this
there we go, see? It would have been so easy if I'd just gotten here but I got the other, the people like
up my ass with oh fuck off with that
just, ugh, fucking go away
there we go, fuck you, fuck, fuck you, fuck you, I'm coming for ya fuck you
what is this? what is this?
what is this?
what the..?
ugh fuck off, do not kill me
how
what the hell?
see it looks like someone just spewed randomly but it what? there, yes, ok good
I got it...fuck
it even prevented me from getting a one up
seems like someone just randomly spat shit here and hoped for the best
this was not planned, this level had no planning
this level is bullshit and I hate it
and I got the world record? fuck that
oh my god, alright I'm gonna start the next one and if it's not good right off the bat than I'm just gonna
fuck it
fuuuuck it
fuck it, at least I did it, I didn't, I didn't, I didn't give up
I got 44 left to go to the end and I'm hoping I'm gonna get some one ups here
oh this looks...interesting
I'm breaking out of here you sacks of crap
fuck you all
so far so interesting, oooh hello
ok, yeah, they'll never see me
in this disguise. Oh I forgot I can't jump
er I can't criss cross jump
oh ok well this seems rather precarious what happens if it goes bad?
oh shit, don't, ooohh
don't lose it...fuck
oh fuck, oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no
oh I can't get through if I don't get that?
aahh that's such dicketry
ah I shouldda held onto it anyway but goddamn it, ok
so I got ya, I got ya, I understand ya
I'm gonna give this one more try
in this playthrough
and then, and then I'm not gonna quit on it, I'm just saying that
you know, going to different ventures
ok, this time don't be a fool
don't be a goddamn fool like that, don't be a frickin fool
ok so hopefully I'm just gonna gun straight to em, cap em out, like so
and then get the new one here
and then I'll be good, then just avoid the bullet bongos
at least I'm short enough that I don't need to worry about that
that's awfully handy that is
hop boink ok
boink and boink ok so far so good
boink, ok, follow these guys in
it's so stealthy, they'll never know that I'm here
ok chase this guy down
there's, oh that looks like deathly fire down there I always like deathly fire, why did I come up here?
probably for nothing
at least I still have this, ok
I'm assuming this is just gonna be another mush
ok, gaaaaaaaaaaa
woooo wooo I didn't actually expect to make it through there
well that looks precarious and dangerous
how are we gonna avoid all that death?
eheheheheheeeh
ok the guard dog is being, woah that ain't good
hup hvvv ok he did nothing
useless as it could be
ok go fire quickly, up, nah, ain't gonna do it
next time, this time
woop riskin it aaahh yes, ok
woooh so so far it's not that bad
am I supposed to, no
no, no way, I'm supposed to go up here
with this, woo hey
woah watch it with those things
you'll put someone's eye out, wooo, oooh, fuck
aaahhh fuck off yes ok
that's something, at least it's something, ok
hup, there we go, oh freeeeeedddooom
let's hope I don't die, ok so this is a faith jump
I'm gonna go for this
and hope for the beeeeessst
ooohhhh yeaaaaahhhh
haaaaa
and two one ups how bout that jazz? so
thank you everybody so much for watching, I made it through two levels but that first one was a bitch
but I got through it so thank you again
and as always, I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
how in thirty sec.. fuck you